اذا ينضم الان الينا في هذه التغطيه من
علامه مشاهدينا حتى الان حسب مراسل
العربيه ثمانيه قتلى حتى الان 8
اسرائيليين قتلوا في اطلاق النار في اييي
بالقرب من كنيس يهوديه في مستوطنه النبي
يعقوب شرق القدس ينضم الينا الان زياد
حلبي مراسلنا من هناك زياد اهلا بك اخر
المعلومات لديك
هذا صحيح حصيله القتله ثمانيه مستوطنين
قتلوا في مستوطنه النبي يعقوب الواقعه همم
عمليا بالقرب من حي بيت حنينا شمالي القدس
الشرقيه المحتله علامه بانك فلسطينيه
كان يبحث على ما يبدو على اهداف لاطلاق
النار فتح النار همم ترجع من السياره وفتح
النار تجاه مجموعه من المستوطنين ما ادى
الى مقتل 28
ادعاء الاسرائيلي عن شخص اخر سعاده ما
يبدو انه كان يقود السياره عمليا وفاره
منها راجل ايضا ما زال يبحثون عنه جرى
اغلاق المنطقه همم بالكامل همم بطبيعه
الحال هناك مشاورات هي الان يجريها
بنيامين نتنياهو
يعني دراسه ما يمكن ان يتفعله
اسرائيل عن هذه العمليه الموجعه في القدس
الهواء قبل قليل يعني نتحدث عن السياره
البيضاء التي كنا نشاهدها قبل قليل هي
سياره
مفتوحه نعم نعم نعم طيب هل تاكد اذا كان
همم الشخص كان وحيدا ام كان معه شخص اخر
يعني عندما قتلته الشرطه كان وحيدا في
السياره كان هو الذي يقود
الاشتباع بانه هناك شخص اخر فر لم يشارك
اخر قد فرى من المنطقه يشتبهون عمليا انه
قد يكون من ساعده ربما كان من يقود
السياره عمليا لان المنسد ترجل من هذه
السياره البيضاء وفتح النار همم وبالتالي
اشتبك ايضا بعدها مع الشرطه الاسرائيليه
همم بالاضافه الى ذلك التقديرات لدى ال-
الشرطه الاوليه في التحقيق الاول
بانفد ومن صعده همم
المحتله بمعنى يحملون الهويه الزرقاء
ويوجد ايضا المسدس الذي كان بحوزته من نوع
السياره وهو مسدس محلي الصنع مصنع محليا
عمليا احنا ولكن مسدس محلي
محلي الصنع همم يعني ادى الى هذه الحصيله
ال- ال- الكبيره نسبيا يعني
هذا صحيح يعني اطلق النار من مسافه قصيره
عمليه اطلق اكثر من 20 رصاصه وبالتالي هذا
قد يفسر هذه ال ال الحصيله عمليه من هذا
المسدس الذي يصنع في بعض الاماكن الشمالي
الضفه الغربيه المختلفه طيب هذا الهجوم
طبعا ياتي في اجواء متوتره ومشحونه كذلك
على خلفيه كذلك تصعيد الاسرائيلي في جنين
اخر المعطيات لديك كذلك همم
زياده وهل كانت اسرائيل تنتظر يعني هذا
الرد
بدون مشاكل بان العمليه في المستوصله في
القدس مرتبطه ارتباطا وثيقا في المجزره في
جديد وما حدث اسرائيل كانت تدرك تماما بان
عمليات رجفه ستكون اذا كان في الدقه
الغربيه او في القدس او داخل حتى الخط
الاخضر بالاضافه الى جبهه قطاع غزه
وبالفعل هذا ما كان هذه عمليه همم صهيب
تسمى عمليه فرديه لدى الاسرائيليين مشكله
في منعها لان عمليا لا معلومات
استخباراتيه
ويتوجه الى مكان ما ويفتح النار همم عاده
لا يستطيعون وقف مثل هذه العمل طيب حدثني
عن النبي يعقوب كيف هو الوضع في الحي الان
وفي القدس عموما
طبعا هذه مستوطنه كبيره يسكنها في الاثاث
متدينون يهود هي ملاصقه كما قلت لحي بيت
حنينه شمالي القدس ااا مستوطنه يعيش فيها
عشرات الالاف من المستوطنين حاليا هي سكن
عسكريه بكل معنى
خاصه نعم
وصلت الى المكان وهناك شرطه همم كانت وصلت
بك اعداد كبيره بالاضافه الى طواقم
الاسعاف التي هرعت طبعا انا سمعتها كلها
يعني انا اسكن حنينه ليست بعيدا عن عن هذا
المكان
وبالتالي الان اغلق همم الحي همم الاحياء
العربيه المساخنه اغلقت بالكامل عزلت عن
هذه المستوطنه ربما ايضا في محاوله لمنع
من يدعون بانه مساعد المنفذ ان ربما يفلح
في ال- ال-
نعم طيب ايه فيما يتعلق
بهذا بهذه المنطقه الان اييي هل تعتقد او
هل تترقب اسرائيل مدام انه هناك هذا
التصعيد في جنين وهذه العمليه المنفرده
كما ذكرت ااا نفذها احد الاشخاص من حمله
الهويه الزرقاء هل تترقب اسرائيل عمليات
اخرى همم حتى وان كان غير منسقه زياد
بدون شكل
صهيب ايضا من جوانبها المعروفه جدا بانها
يعني هناك تقليد في هذه العمليات عندما
تكون عمليه بين مزدوجين ناجحه بمعنى
يفلحون فيها في في قتلى وجرحها عمليا هناك
من يقوم بها بعمليه مشابهه في وقت ما في
مكان ماء ليس شرطا في القدس او في مكان
اخر ربما داخل في الضفه الغربيه ايضا
بالده اهداف للجيش او للمستوطنات هذا
رايناه في السنتين يتكرر تباع هذه هذا
النوع من العمليات الفرديه التي كما قلنا
لدى اسرائيل صعوبه كبيره في مواجهتها
لانها عمليه حتى من ينفذ عاده صهيب لا
يكون منتميا بالضروره لفصيل فلسطين
هذا العمليه بشكل فردي وبقرار همم طيب همم
نعرف الان هناك ثمانيه قتل اسرائيليين على
الاقل 10 جرحى هل لديك اي معلومات اذا
كانت حاله الجرحى المتبقين خطره ام لا
بمعنى ان تكون الحصيله مرشحه للارتفاع ام
لا زياد
هذا شبه اكيد صهيب
بانهاديات لان عمليا هناك خمسه جرحه حاله
الثلاث اثنين منهم عفوا حرجه للغايه وحال
ثلاثه اخرين عمليه وصفت بالخطيره بهذا
المعنى نعم يمكن ان نتوقع عند الحصيله همم
تزداد كما قلنا المنافذ ترجع ومن مسافه
قصيره جدا عمليا همم اطلق النار نعم طيب
همم زياد ولكن همم حدثني كذلك على مساله
التصعيد في جنين والتي يمكن
هي هذه العمليه الان في النبي يعقوب هي
مرتبطه بها كذلك همم اخر معطيات ال- ال-
التصعيد في جنين كذلك وما اسفر عنه
طبعا التصعيد في جنين ينبع نبع من ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اقتحم جديد
ونابلس شمال تحديدا
سوهاجت
ان للمخيمات لكن بدون ان شده للحصيله في
جنين ربما تكون كسرت قواعد اللعبه نوعا ما
همم بهذه العمليات الان المتوتره يعني
راينا بالامس مثلا مواجهه محدوده في جبهه
قطاع غزه اطلاق صواريخ اسرائيليه سرعان ما
تم احتواء الامر ولكن مثل هذه العمليات لا
احد عمليا لديه سيطره عليها من الجانبين
بهذا ال-
طبعا
الاستعداد الامر
شكرا جزيلا لك زياده حتى الان همم بالفعل
بالتاكيد سنبقى في متابعه معك ومع زميل
عبد الحفيظ كذلك شبكه مراسلين ايضا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه لمتابعه تطورات هذا
الخبر المتفاعل اذا مشاهدينا ما نعلمه حتى
الان مقتل ثمانيه اسرائيليين في عمليه
نفذها فلسطينيه على ما يبدو من حمله
الهويه الزرقاء همم في همم مستوطنه نبي
يعقوب بالقرب من كنيس يهوديه هذا الحي
تقطنه اغلبيه من المتدينين
اليهود
وهناك 10 جرحى على الاقل كما ذكر مرتين
قبل قليل عددهم همم يعني حاله بعضهم خطره
ما يجعل هذه الحصيله مرشحه للارتفاع
القوات الامنيه الاسرائيليه قامت بتحييد
منفذ هذا الهجوم كنا نشاهد سيارته قبل
قليل على الهواء وقامت القوات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه باغلاق جميع منافذ القدس بعد
هذه العمليه التي تاتي غاداتها تصعيد
اسرائيلي في القدس في جنين عفوا همم بحياه
فلسطينيين على الاقل